So you're about to watch the Udacity
interview confessionals.
This is a montage video of Udacity
employees talking about various
interview fails that they've
gone through in their careers.
We show you these videos not because
we want to scare you off of interviews.
But to show you that while it might feel
very isolating to to go on an interview
on your own, we all go through the same
kind of mistakes and pains that you
probably are going through or
have gone through or will go through.
And hopefully you'll remember these
videos and remember that each
opportunity that you have going into an
interview is an opportunity to practice.
And an opportunity to move
forward in your career.
Good luck.